Ryan why don't why don't you introduce
yourself let's go right into the origin
story
I think obviously given that this is the
real estate tract by show of hands how
many people know who this extremely
handsome man is okay so obviously I
think a lot of people know who you are
but is there anything that you want to
cover or stuff that hasn't been covered
by the show or the mainstream media from
a nuance something that you think brings
value obviously you got to hear the
opening keynote so maybe there's some
build on that as I just setting this up
before we kind of go into a little bit
of a chat here is there is there
anything you think they should know sure
I mean I am the original anti salesman
like by far I never wanted to be a real
estate broker in my entire life I think
if you told me when I was 10 years old
that I was gonna grow up to be a real
estate broker let her live a real estate
broker on TV I would have said that
you're [ __ ] crazy I won't because I
never wanted a real job right that was
the one thing I ran away from as hard as
possible and to like real estate like
really especially when I was a little
kid like I saw the real estate agents
that my parents worked with it's like I
don't want to do that I want to be
awesome I want to be a broker that's
terrible and then I grew up and I went
to New York City to try to be an actor
and that was way harder than Brad Pitt
makes it seem and and that was a wake up
call
and I grew up outside Boston and then
went to college yeah and then I went to
college in upstate New York I just
realized there's a lot more patriot
fancier than I wanted to get it wait
could I could I break from the origin
story for one second tell a funny story
so I meet Gary for the first time well I
met it before but we actually had
breakfast on Monday morning and we sit
there and we sit down and one of the
first things he says to me is you know
what I don't talk about the Patriots
because the Patriots are just won the
AFC Championship right on Sunday since
there's nothing you Ryan this was three
days ago everybody's falling
good and he's such a diehard awesome
Jets fan which i think is I think it's
great right to have love and everything
for a sport that way and he said there's
nothing I hate more than a 33 year old
Patriots fan so I'm 33 and I grew up
outside Boston and I'm a proud patriot
and it's okay yeah all right you know
you know it's just like actually just to
build on something earlier my theory on
30 I can't believe that I did say that I
said I was talking about the Patriots
and I was talking about like if you're
33 and you've been a patriot fan or
you're a Boston fan you suck similar to
the point that I was making out there
about if you weren't punched in the
mouth yet because you've been in
business since 2009 if you're 33 and a
Boston sports fan you've won all four
championships you win all the time and
so in a weird way I think that slightly
makes you a loser I do I do
Monday I tell these two ladies who you
are because they were whispering to each
other like who is that right so for
people who don't know who I am
might is this on right you can you run
yeah my name is Ryan Serhant and I do a
TV show on Bravo called million dollar
listing New York and I've been on since
the beginning we started taping that
show in 2010 it didn't come out to 2012
and right now we're taping season 7 and
I actually have my own show on Bravo now
called sell it like Serhant that will
premiere this spring I'm not allowed to
tell you when yet because it's it's a
it's a big date and it'll come out this
spring and it's just me so you better
watch it all these people in here it's
the first kind of business show that
Bravo has done like this and so it's
gonna be pretty cool [ __ ] DVR do we
still have those do they slixa know
right like it's un-fuckin'-believable
these technologies come in and out
alright so right yeah didn't want to do
that but you did you know you were
telling your origin story you said a
real estate broker but one on TV that
caught my attention because you did come
you like you did want to be a TV at you
wanted to be an actor yeah I when did
that happen
uh when I was like four I think I made
my little brother do little home movies
with me my mom was the videographer
I made at this whole trove of home
movies that I made where I killed my
little brother I don't know why every
single movie he just happens to die
isn't named Kenny yeah yeah it's Jack
and I no matter what though I knew that
I wanted to grow up and be successful no
matter what I did I thought it was gonna
be acting I thought I was gonna be on
Broadway right that was my thing and it
didn't work out for me and I thought
that that was devastating I did a soap
opera for a little short period of time
when I first came to New York and they
killed me off karma right and they
killed me off what show what yeah as the
world turns
I took a I took haven't washed the
fourth that's who I was and I took a
syringe to the heart while I was on top
of a hospital awaiting my helicopter to
take me to the Caribbean where I could
do my research and peace and that was
and then I thought my life was over
and I had no money and I lived in Korea
town and it was go home to Colorado or
my parents then move to and paint fence
for the rest of my life or was oh your
parents lived in Colorado yeah how long
they moved to Colorado when I graduated
high school in 2002 it's gonna make a
point about the Patriots thing but keep
going to you
so so I didn't want to go home and I
said you know what I'll stay in New York
I got to make this work because from
when I was a little kid I chose success
first whatever I was gonna do to be
successful I would figure out later and
I mean a lot of people who say I want to
be successful real estate agent but they
choose real estate first so they choose
something else first and I think that's
where a lot of people that make the
mistake because if they have a small
little hiccup or a small little bump in
the road
it's like world over for them oh I lost
that deal world what am I gonna do all
my life is over
but if you choose success first that's
what I did so I had no money I lived in
Koreatown I I didn't want to go home and
so I got my real estate license it was
like 300 bucks at the time and I rented
apartments for a thousand two thousand
bucks a month on 31st and 32nd Street
and I did shares I found three people
put them in a one-bedroom put up fake
walls I ran all over the place I didn't
have a suit and that's what I did and
then there was an open casting call in
the real deal and curbed
for a show called million dollar listing
New York which is gonna be the New York
franchise of the LA show and I went to
an open casting call at the Hudson hotel
with 3,000 agents and they took everyone
seconds at a time with 3000 of us and
they said why should you be on the show
and I said why the [ __ ] do you think I
should be on this show your face no I
just said all I said was I'm the
greatest and they bought it and then I
had to figure it out after six months of
casting and they said okay we're gonna
put you on the show and there were four
of us the greatest definitely came out
of your mouth but were you able to say
like on a very very tangible note were
you able to say hey look I was on the
[ __ ] as the world turns like
obviously I'm in the game like did that
click on a very serious kick uh not
really
you know because I they were really
pushing to find the best real estate
agents in New York City which you
weren't I know they started casting at
the beginning 2010 my first day in real
estate brokerage at all with September
15 2008 that was the day Lehman Brothers
filed for bankruptcy which is the only
reason I know that date because that was
my first day in the conference room like
dude we're gonna be awesome everyone
staring at the TV is the world comes
crashing down and for a lot of people
right
it was awful for me I had no money for
everybody to because I think I'm gonna
bounce a little bit from the talk
earlier we keep it's interesting I
almost feel weird because I feel like
we're about to predict like a crash like
they we keep referencing this day back
in in 2008 just for again for people
that are early in their career or were
in different businesses on that day
within 24 hours Wine Library when you
when you sell wine you can pre-sell it
and you can sell futures so we get to
take the money and and the customer gets
to save a lot of money on a wine that
comes out 18 months later and you can
only do that with the most sought-after
wine right no different than the most
sought-after anything that you do right
literally within 24 hours of that day we
had 1.7 million dollars of 2.4 million
dollars of Bordeaux that was sold have
to be refunded because that many people
knew the world had just crashed or
worked at a Wall Street firm like
literally that's how much it melted
literally and don't forget we're playing
on that float so we're using those
dollars for other things cuz it's in and
you know up into that point for you know
nine years we had one
cent cancellations so it was a
significant I mean like you're not
joking like if you walked in like you
know wide-eyed and excited like
literally the veterans in that office
were like [ __ ] we're about to go through
a three to five year window of straight
[ __ ] yeah and so hindsight is 20/20 so
it was the worst time to get started in
business but at the same time it was the
absolute best time because a lot of
brokers were getting out of the business
right the guy who got me into the
business a friend of mine from college
he was selling apartments on Craigslist
that's all he needed to do we put ads on
Craigslist would meet people on the
street corner take them a few buildings
in New York City they'd buy one
contracts were signed on the spot ten
percent deposit stated income loans all
day that was it the day I started all of
that disappeared so with the reason I
got into the business hey bro it's just
Craigslist we're gonna [ __ ] kill it
that's what and people were starting up
brokerages everywhere right when times
are great everyone can do anything and
so I said okay I'll do this to pay my
rent pay for food and that way I can go
to auditions and do things you know that
I want to do on my own and then the
minute I did my first deal and I made a
thousand dollars because I rented a two
thousand dollar a month apartment and
commissions you know in New York City
anyway our one month's rent let's say on
a rental and a brand new broker you take
fifty-fifty with the house and that was
a one day showing I got a thousand
dollars and I was rich and I remember
that day it was models and bottles all
day so
you so you flew back to Boston because
you definitely couldn't afford to that
in New York which is a first-rate City
well exactly my rent where I was was
eleven eleven hundred and sixty-seven
dollars at the time so that was towards
rent and then I just wanted to make sure
that I did as many deals as possible
then all of a sudden I was like wait a
minute there's only so much time in the
day why am i spending so much time going
to Actors Equity auditions and sitting
here and being told no to my face and
know about my gray hair and know about
this and know about that it's so
personal when I can meet people on the
street I could show them apartments that
aren't mine I don't have to do anything
else other than make personal
connections and then if they like a
space I get paid for it
like I don't I didn't create anything
especially when I was a brand new agent
I was like this is a job and anybody can
do it you can get off a boat in New York
City with under five hundred dollars and
that is it you can in you can make
millions and millions of dollars and all
you have to do is meet human beings and
that that was my aha moment right and
there was a guy if you have the
serendipity of your parents having sex
at the exact moment that gave you the
charisma and people skills to be able to
do that right I mean I think the thing
that's super interesting for me from
afar about this industry is that I'll
respond to the the the the game is
extremely lucrative for a certain
personality trait to me what's so
attractive about this industry is it is
the greatest ROI if you have a certain
human skill because there's a ton of
people who can never sell anything
because their personal skills suck right
like the emotional intelligence which is
emerging in society period has always
been a huge arbitrage in real estate no
I'm asking I disagree go ahead I when I
first got into real estate that was my
one deal I got addicted and then like
most people who get into real estate I
did no deals and then I couldn't figure
it out I was like this sucks this sucks
but there was a guy in my office his
name was Ben and he was from bed-stuy
Brooklyn get his first kid when he was
17 Ben from bed-stuy
yeah okay keep going right get his first
kid when he was 17 he sold drugs and he
got into real estate to help pay the
bills and he did deals every single day
cuz he was a drug dealer that's the best
[ __ ] training in the game maybe maybe
I only want a higher drug but he was
completely quiet
you should guys drug-dealing I listen I
make a lot of content for 15 to 17
year-olds on Instagram and I hit up Dee
I talked to them on DM all the time and
these kids are [ __ ] selling a lot of
weed and I'm like dick face do you
understand that you all you have to do
is just take that same skill and make
that about Yeezys and Supremes and
you'll make 10x the money and you'll be
legit I mean drug dealing is the
training ground for gangsters and sales
because not only do you have to sell you
have to [ __ ] navigate the law and
your parents I'm a big fan of drug
dealers no one who works for me sells
drugs by the way but I don't think it's
just charisma I think anybody can sell
anybody can be taught to sell obviously
there are people with natural-born
Talent who have charisma who have great
personalities and they're people people
but then there are other people that
don't like that like I that's why I
started this conversation by saying that
I was the anti salesmen dude I was
overweight chubby face riddled with acne
when I was in high school I didn't want
to talk to anybody my Saturday nights
were snick right there's guys in here
that I went to high school with I didn't
have that many friends I didn't want to
talk to anybody I was shy totally ruined
my self-confidence the last thing I ever
wanted to do was go into Starbucks in
Manhattan and try to talk to people
about renting apartments are you kidding
me I'm talking about but my back was up
against the wall because I had no money
so I had to figure out okay if I'm gonna
stay here I've got my real estate
license I might as well figure out how
to do this I'm gonna leave my my
self-consciousness and my ego at the
door whatever that might be and I'm just
gonna start Hawking real estate I'm
gonna talk about it like I know what I'm
talking about I'm just gonna figure it
out and then I worked every single day
and that's what the new show on Bravo is
about it's called sell it like Serhant
and it's working with people who are the
worst salespeople in the history of the
world and you will see it is ridiculous
and helping them through what their
hurdles
our figuring out what their wall is
figuring out what their what is what
their who is what their win is right if
your win is just to make a lot of money
it's gonna be hard for you is how do you
work towards that every day I'm gonna
make a lot of money today okay great go
okay go do it but if you figure out what
your win is and what your wall is like
what what's the worst thing that could
happen to you if you don't sell
something today that's your motivation
for tomorrow and I think that anybody
who doesn't have a great personality or
great charisma right now can become a
great salesperson if they work at it but
everybody has different hurdles they got
to get over do you or do you so let's
talk about this to make it about the
audience obviously as your profile grew
with the success of the show what is the
majority of questions you're being asked
via DMS on Instagram via email when
somebody stops you in the street what is
the what is the current state of
questions in the sector that are coming
to you based on where you're positioned
in the market everybody asks how to get
started I mean everybody asks me how do
I get started or they've been in the
business for a year or two and they
don't know how to get started that's
what everybody wants to know even
downstairs we were on you know the field
with you and people asking what do I do
like how do i how do I get over that
kind of like first up in the business I
don't know anybody I don't have
connections I don't have I don't even
know you know the paperwork what do I do
and I tell everybody there's two things
you need to do no matter what right you
meet five new people every single day
because you have to add to your social
currency we talked about that right you
got to add to your database your data
book right your your rolodex your your
excel sheet whatever you use and you
have to work with somebody else you
cannot do it by yourself that was the
biggest mistake that I made that a lot
of people think they can get into real
estate they got their license boom I'm
gonna be the best broker ever work with
someone who's been in the business
forever work for them for free just
listen to the conversation listen to how
they talk to people look at how they
write their emails meet the brokers that
they know meet the clients that they
know learn from them take the best leave
the rest and do it on your own that's
what I tell people that's that's it
it's interesting to me obviously we talk
you know you've gotten passionate about
teaching sales you reverse engineer
yourself because it didn't come
naturally you just told your high school
story which was fun do you think it's
better for people to who don't you know
so I think you think about sales the way
I think about any skill and I agree with
you which is everybody here can be
better at everything you could be a
better singer than you are right now my
biggest question always is you could be
better at basketball you could be better
at playing American football but I have
a good feeling that you weren't built to
be on the field here every Sunday I'm
very fascinated by the Mendoza line of
somebody trying to become a salesperson
get better at sales what's their upside
because I agree with you they can go
from here to here but does it close the
Delta that they should do that versus
spending a lot of time trying a lot of
different things and becoming self-aware
and figuring out the thing that has
their biggest upside when you think
about this and as you're you know you're
going through
probably a process that happened similar
to me it was you know my first decade in
business it was about me establishing
what I wanted then you start reversing
you start asking yourselves like how the
[ __ ] did this happen why is this
happening
start thinking about your pain how you
were parented where you were where you
come from a lot of you know I talk about
a lot of this stuff I was just curious
for myself and I thought it'd be
interesting here do you think that sales
is such an incredibly core skill set
that everybody should try to get better
at that or do you think that some people
just have this little upside with that
and the real game is self-awareness and
trying to figure themselves out because
there's maybe they're an operator maybe
they're a back-office person may be
owning 3% of a company where somebody
else is doing all that magic because
they're just organized and meticulous
and that's they've got huge upside and
that they'll never drop any ball but
really their sales will only go up so
where do you put sales as a skill and
it's upside versus self-awareness for
one I think that everybody's a
salesperson what do you think you are or
not
right I mean when I was a little kid
like I said right I've had a little bit
of a weight problem I was selling my mom
on giving me
pudding-like I really like those jello
snack packs with whipped cream on top
and I like to have three of them I don't
know why that was a problem and so my
mom my parents didn't want me to eat
that much and I had to negotiate with
them I just sell them on why I should
have an extra one I balanced out time
instead of having them all right at 4
o'clock so you know what I do one for
one at 7 and then if I do this one thing
for you I'll get one before I go to bed
and that's where I really learned how to
sound all of us sell something even if
your back office even if your IT you are
selling a program you are selling your
system of how to manage email you're
selling the fact that you need to come
in at 5 o'clock because that's better
for your schedule than coming in at 9:00
when it's better for your client
schedule so we're all salespeople and we
can all become better salespeople which
will help us do better than whatever it
is our job is but I agree with you in a
little bit that I don't think everybody
should be a real estate agent I don't
feel that everybody should be selling
body lotion on the street right I worked
with someone on the show who did that
that's the only reason I mentioned that
but I think that you have to find what
you love and that you can that you can
actually make money doing all right I
kind of hate it when people say do what
you love and you'll never work a day in
your life that's that's great if you
[ __ ] have money do you think that
right so honestly I'm very fascinated by
this subject matter I know I live a very
interesting life I was such a terrible
student that a lot of my high school and
specifically my college friends and even
less so my college friends my college
acquaintances I mean a stunning
percentage of the people that I knew
between 6 & 22 make under $75,000 a year
and a stunning percentage of the people
that I've been doing business with from
2007 to 2012 are makeover or have net
worth over 5 million dollars a year and
I'm and I'm kind of like I live almost
in this bizarro two different world
world and I am fascinated by how many of
my friends that make sixty seven
thousand dollars a year and have hit
their zone are truly truly truly happy
and how many are at seventy million
dollars net worth and are miserable as
[ __ ] like you know to me I genuinely do
believe that
you know rich is a very funny kind of
vague self self kind of inside game so
for example this is just my truth when I
meet $100,000 a year that was like I've
never felt the same way since I've never
felt as at peace as that was a number
for me like I'm comfort I was
comfortable living my lifestyle under
that monarchy I'm fascinated by this
conversation like I really think a lot
more this is why I talk a lot about
doing like going very nice so for me I'm
a big believer that a lot of people here
who make 236 a year should make 147
putting out content around Alf
the sitcom from the 80s like what I'm
fascinated by is the extreme long tail
of the internet and the monetization of
crazy Nisha's how many people here are
familiar with the fact that 8 to 10 year
old 6 to 10 year old girls in America
are making slime at home like in a big
way so good do you know about this
phenomenon No ok so homemade slime right
it's huge
I know I know a couple people who were
in love with arts and crafts loved
making this stuff and have been doing
this and making little videos about
slime making for 6 years and like
literally that was their lives and then
you know the market comes to them they
were making $13,000 a year in Adsense 3
years ago now they're making a million
to two million dollars a year in branded
content and ads and things of that
nature and higher I think this is the
beginning I'm fascinated by the the do
you think the wealth thing and I think
you're right and let me tell you we're
on the subtlety rich or what-have-you
I think it's a lot easier when your
income how much you take home is
controlled by what you spend people get
stressed when their balance sheet and
P&L is broken so some people know how to
live under a hundred thousand and
there's people in here making half a
million but they're buying so much [ __ ]
that they're so vulnerable and deep down
deep down they are stressed because they
know if [ __ ] hits the fan they're [ __ ]
where do you actually sit on this like
happiness of work dollar kind of
conversation like nuanced I heard you
but next level uh I live and I tell
people to live probably ten percent over
comfortable right whatever your comfort
level is don't go a hundred percent over
because we've all read in the news
you've seen the articles you've seen
somebody on the street who who went a
hundred percent over comfortable and
that was stupid right so I never tell
people to live outside their means or to
live at their means either because then
how are you gonna push yourself the only
way that I got over a hundred thousand
dollars a year was by saying this is
great I'm not broke but it's still not
enough right so how are you are you are
you at enough now no do you think you'll
ever be at enough no no that means you
love that means you love the process
that means it's not the money yeah
what's that
she had trust it but like he loves it
trusting it is different than loving it
right like I don't trust that if I work
hard it'll be okay I love working hard
yeah I love [ __ ] I love [ __ ] being
the working dog and I love working for
myself because well he just loves he
just loves what's up Ruben so so so so
so you you you think you love the
process I love to work right I meant the
process and I love I love doing whatever
I want to do every single day and not
having to punch in or punch out I just
didn't want to do it I was like I I'm
gonna live a short life and then I will
die and that will be it
and the worst thing in the world for me
is to say good thing I went to my job
like that sucks and that terrified me
when I was 10 I remember like crying in
the bathtub
I was a weird little kid but I was
crying in the bathtub about like about
growing up doing nothing and then dying
and so I said to myself any clue why
that happened was there like a
grandparent a parent like did you watch
some weird soap opera like do you have
any clue why that was happening I think
a lot of it came from my parents for
sure a lot of it came for my parents I
was raised very very strict and they
always had me work incredibly hard to
understand the value of the dollar the
value of work and the value of making
something of yourself because no one
else is going to do it and that was
that's what was hard for me
acting that I could do the best audition
ever right somebody else had control
yeah someone else had control or someone
else looked a different way or someone
else did you that knowing that you're
vlogging now and building your profile
do you view the way I'm producing media
as potentially a better way than the way
that you're doing it through television
because you have even more control
because listening to you carefully what
must be massively frustrating is the way
they post edit the show when you knew
that you put magic but they're trying to
create a narrative on that episode sort
of I mean listen TV is TV maybe it will
eventually change but networks have been
pretty good recently about adapting
different forms of media and I would not
be here today if it weren't right
ultimately the ROI is so extraordinary
in the direction you can deal with some
of the shortcomings I mean of course and
whatever I put on on TV they it's not
like CGI it was me doing it and if
things get cut for time they get cut for
time but listen million dollar listing
airs to 25 million people around the
world like I can't I can't do that even
on social media I mean not renewed right
yeah maybe eventually but not when I'm a
33 Patriots fan right I get it right I
get it
so especially when you're starting right
that was a huge layup for me oh it's an
it's an it's the catalyst but I think
that what's great now is that you don't
have to wait for a three thousand person
open casting call you could do what
we're talking about any people watch the
show okay great quite a bit so let's get
into some of that who is your favorite
cast member like who are you actually
like friendly with or like let's get
into some of these white I know that
she's right there by the way I know that
I keep looking at her at a corner of my
right eye like she the radar yes she
gives me the sides your lovely wife who
is your favorite and and there's been
different people that have come in and
out honestly like you know there's a
positive this isn't who do you hate who
of the crew have you know the characters
have you liked the most or have a
relationship with or maybe you don't
it's all three of us well there's been
what six of you through the years how
many have there been
New York not so many there was uh there
was
and then there was a model so that's it
six yeah and so yeah I mean I've always
had the best camaraderie even though
we've had some ups and downs but with
Fred because we've been in it together
from the beginning
he's also 10 years older than I am and
so we were never like contemporaries we
weren't peers right I was I was young
and he was doing you know he'd been in
the business for 10 years I still
haven't to this day been in this
business for 10 years my 10 year
anniversary is this September and so he
had already been doing real estate so I
got into it trying to figure out how
that hell am I gonna find listings to
put on a million dollar listing show I'm
I'm renting apartments I told them I was
the greatest broker in the history of
the world holy [ __ ] I gotta figure this
out and that's what I did it was you
know the best thing that the show did
for me was it was a metaphorical shot
gun to my head to not stop working
because the last thing I needed was a
show to millions of people telling
everyone that I sucked at real estate
that would be no good for business so I
made sure that and I always think about
future Ryan Wright myself five years
from now because I don't care about
myself yesterday what he's dead and I
care about myself tomorrow I care about
myself in five years so I think every
day about future Ryan what should i
pitch today that will help future Ryan
and the same thing with the show right
we film a year in advance sometimes I
have a good idea for you real quick
yeah where's your team like the core
content team there there that's Adam
that's Alice that's Jimmy I just have to
get somebody to draw a future Adam a
future Ryan excuse me you have to create
a future Ryan cartoon character and when
you reference it you need to edit it in
cool do that dude I got you it'll be a
stick I think I think I think it's an
interesting thought right like I think
it's super important to prove to not
project like I'm gonna be successful
it's just being it's about being
thoughtful about the chess moves and
creating your strategy of like where you
want to be you know from a happy zone
from a financial zone from a
professional zone yeah because everyone
talks about living in the now like
that's that's great but the now is
whoever you prepared to be for the last
five years right so
you know I know I came to New York City
to be an actor but it's a bit
serendipitous that I quit acting I was
fired but quit got out of it didn't like
it hated that business no one in college
teaches you the business of acting they
teach you how to be a clock and a frog
and that's your craft and then you go to
New York and they're like we don't want
you to be a frog we want you to look
like this and dance like this no okay no
money for you and that by getting out of
it and getting into real estate I then
get back in front of a camera
to do what I wanted to do in the first
place anyway because I set up those
building blocks from the beginning so
that was my story those were my building
blocks you have to figure out what your
own are like what is it maybe it's real
estate in food there are agents I know
who are we're so obsessed with food
that's their passion real estate to them
is a job and so they mix the both every
week they have weekly dinners with their
clients they cook they figure out new
recipes every listing they do they take
listing photos with food in it because
that's what they love that's what gets
them up every single day that's their
thing if your thing is cats cat it up
right well cats everywhere if that's
what makes you happy because progress is
happiness and if you're doing a little
bit more tomorrow than you were doing
today that's gonna set you up for future
you and if you don't think that way then
I don't know that's my stress my stress
is in financial stress even if I buy
something even if I do something I know
I'm gonna work my ass off everything's
gonna be okay I don't let that affect me
what I let affect me is that I'm not
planning and then I'm not using enough
of my potential because one day I will
be dead right and you know you talk
about this a lot as well you know that
one day we will be dead and did you milk
your potential as much as you possibly
could I think that's why say be five
people a day I think it's hard to
quantify how ridiculously rare it is to
become a human being it's just not what
we think about and then how quickly it
all happens right like I mean it just
goes so fast right you know it it's the
same old thing in life right it takes
forever but it's it seems like yesterday
but yeah I just I don't to me the bigger
issue at hand
is the practical things like there were
humans like us who lived during the
Black Plague like that was in the world
and a stunning amount of us died people
that live during the great you know are
the greatest generation we talked a lot
about in the u.s. we're like you know
for a lot of people that were born in
the late 1800s like you know
nineteen hundred's the prime of their
live their lives were during you know
real conflict in the world wars and
things that nature we all of us everyone
from the oldest person here to the
youngest have lived in unbelievable
prosperity like it has been so
uncomplicated history to like things are
things wrap around data it is very
impossible for me to get excited about
complaining about dumb [ __ ] like like
the line was too long or I got the wrong
I got skim milk and said I'm and like
stuff that I hear people talk about when
we as humans are living through the
greatest era that humans have ever lived
through of prosperity and wealth and
happiness and health this is ridiculous
and now on top of that you layer this
thing called the Internet
which is a new invention on the consumer
side and scales the living [ __ ] out of
all of our ambitions and wants and
eliminates the middleman that you hate
so much
winners hate the middle man because
that's somebody that can stop merit what
bothered you was merit what I am blown
away by by the Internet and we're all
your opportunity said is the merit of it
all if you're not doing well it's cuz
you suck the market is telling you you
suck I love how people like how the [ __ ]
is that person got eighty seven thousand
followers she sucks I'm like well you
suck more because you have thirteen
hundred and you've decided to make that
your judgment and not that you should
trade on followers but like the day of
judging you know back in the day Rick
the casting guy decided you weren't cute
enough smile enough funny enough so Rick
could have been flawed we are now living
in a platform that is exposing the
truths if you're not doing well it means
you're not good at it and so many people
spending time trying to tear down other
people's buildings instead of focusing
on how to getting their [ __ ] together
what up what I got an interesting
question here that I've been thinking
about what what happens to future Ryan
in five years like where are you like
right this second you're thinking about
him I'm dying to hear your
current bullet points on him someone
just asked me that on the field they
thought where where is everything gonna
be in five years and I think more than
just me I think I mean how many people
in here are real estate agents or real
estate brokers all of them this is the
real estate track oh thanks
just wanna make sure I do these things
and I ask that in like four people raise
their hands on my car I went to the
wrong one so the ion estanque within the
next five years the brokerage model as
we know in the United States will be
over that is my that is my prediction so
let's go let's go that's a hyperbole
statement it's a short period of time
give me the nuances underneath that I'm
naive I don't even know what the broken
smile is explain in detail what you mean
by that
it's extrapolating on what you're
talking about right now it's that
anybody can market themselves in any
other way they want they can cut out the
middle person why do I have to go to a
brokerage that takes 20% 10% 30% 50% for
me to go and meet somebody to make money
when I showed them an apartment or sell
them in apartments what's what's the
brokerage for I understand that there's
there's a legal need for it now but do
you think that that's going to change
but you've got five years are you guys a
little bit are you gonna start your own
brokerage I I don't think it's gonna be
a brokerage I don't like the idea of
having a brokerage I don't want people
to feel like like I own them in some way
right like if anyone here leaves their
brokerage today any of your contracts
that you have signed that you haven't
been paid on that brokerage is like ha
ha ha ha ha I did nothing for this and I
will take a massive cut and you can't go
do what you want to do some of you might
have great agreement some of you might
be able to cut and run I don't know what
your situation is but most people
they're tied into that brokerage and
that's a thing but this is a brokerage
keeps you leads every day do they supply
anything else other than maybe some
admin work you can do with a TaskRabbit
right like they say there is an app for
that
it's an app it's an app you should look
it up yeah you can do things on your own
now you don't need that brokerage to pay
for that person to do that thing because
everything is automated everything is
automated
oh wait and YouTube everything's out
there you're not I used to do it anymore
guys wait till we get to AI and machine
learning tasks rabbits gonna seem
archaic it's just gonna
automatically happen and I think that
instead of having some powerhouse
brokerages you're just gonna have a lot
of awesome brokers who work for
themselves are working individual teams
and that's all that needs to happen and
so what I want to work towards and you
can tell anybody that I said I just
don't care and so right well good news
it's being filmed at scale so this is
not about telling anybody the data is
there it'll be on the web in a second I
think what's interesting to me is it's
how AJ and I view the sports
representation business right
we started Vayner sports because when we
look at the agents that are taking
commissions for doing what has in the
past been important or had a value but
now has become completely different and
so for me as you're talking like oh I
see we saying it's the same as every
business you know what brokerages are
gonna have to do is they're gonna have
to evolve like for example Vayner has a
much better chance to start a brokerage
because instead of you want to do it
maybe I think in you know I because what
I'm realizing is like oh I see we can
take those fat Commission's and those
healthy commissions but what we'll do is
we'll create a model where it's not
about back-office or history we're gonna
build out people's personal brands at
scale which is actually gonna lead them
into real revenue I'm Anna Vince mix man
you right I'm gonna make you the
Ultimate Warrior I'm gonna make you
Hillbilly Jim that's where the money
really is it's an actually doing
something that's tangible in reality so
even though everybody could be a badass
broker a lot of people what they really
need is brand equity so that the funnel
comes in and that's the only thing the
veiner machine is is it's a
communication you know Deathstar and so
that's what it's gonna turn into yeah I
mean look it's you know in New York
anyway right we have business we have
designer gyms right there's designer
gyms all the time there's everywhere
there's Barry's bootcamp there's Rumble
there's their soul cycle there's all
these designer gyms I remember when you
used to go to the gym to lift weights or
get on the treadmill now especially in
New York and other urban areas you go to
work out because of a person you go to
work out at not at 9:00 a.m. because
that's when it's good for you you go at
10:00 a.m. you work your schedule around
because you're going with that trainer
and that trainer isn't working at the
best right and
we're addicted to it now I know in New
York we are people are addicted to their
trainers and we wrap our lives around
those people and the gym space right the
equinoxes of the world have embraced
that and they're changing that model
same thing is brokered you don't go to a
Douglas Elliman right because you're
gonna work with that chairman or that
brand right you're going to that
specific agent and so then what's the
brand for what's it really do anymore
and now I understand that right now
still does a little bit right because
the our generation my generation needs
to get a little bit older to phase
things out and we will enact that change
and I will be at the front of it I swear
to you that sounds like a good admission
I mean look look what you know listening
to the scattering of claps when when you
talk about change
everybody just listen to that from their
perspective so everybody just consumed
your you know four-minute rant on this
issue of squeezing out the middle right
this is all I think about and I think a
lot of what you're talking about is a
good subject to spend the rest of time
because what when I was listening to the
collapse and the energy of the room
everybody just consumed from their
perspective if you're new right if
you're early in your career like yeah
that's exactly right like what the [ __ ]
if you're actually a brokerage you're
like [ __ ] this dude like this is how
this is how I make my dollars but but
this is super important for our buddy
understand I spent a lot of time with
companies that look like toys or I spent
I loved Toys R Us growing up it was the
Kingdom
like when my sister and I got to go to
Toys R Us it was like greatest but that
was like everything right so and and
Toys R Us is based in New Jersey right
and so for the last four years I've
taken four to six different meetings
different restarts and resets with the
CEO or the CMO of Toys R Us over the
last six years because it was
emotionally interesting you know back to
like being able to do anything you
wanted every time it wasn't gonna be the
biggest scope or the best use of my time
it was just fun for me because it
brought back great memories and I wanted
Toys R Us as a client and I would go in
there and every time I would tell them
you were in deep [ __ ] [ __ ] there's
basic data here Walmart is getting way
too much of the toy business that looks
like you right and Amazon's coming for
your lunch and
influencers are gonna start selling this
stuff on YouTube kids directly and where
are you going and because they didn't
like what they were hearing they didn't
hire me or and a lot of times people
don't hire me they'll just change you
don't want to pay our premium they go
for the second-rate thing or the
third-rate thing or try to do it
internally right and and do it
themselves but Toys R Us didn't either
Toys R Us has out of business tours has
no reason for being out of business they
could have made exclusive deals they
could have sold directly all the Toys R
Us is in the country could have turned
into entertainment systems and centers
you don't want to spend time with their
kids you gonna drop them off there for
[ __ ] three hours and left they could
have [ __ ] dominated but because they
were emotional about how they got there
so for everybody who was just listening
to Ryan and didn't like what was coming
out of his mouth what I tell you to do
is realize take your money decide if you
think he's right I'll give you the
preview he's right it's the Internet my
friends it's the [ __ ] Internet it's
not him or me it's the Internet it
eliminates everything that is commodity
so listen very carefully and adjust your
model to be hey you know it doesn't have
to determine brokerage I'm a agency
vaynermedia is an agency no different
than [ __ ] in your world the Elman and
Remax or Weikart or whatever all that's
in that world like we have it to Ogilvy
and [ __ ] you know WPP and all this
we're the same but we're different and I
think for everybody who cares to be
who's on the other side of the
conversation right now who's a brokerage
or building one or about to build one or
cares about one you can still do that
what you provide has to change
you could build a huge toy store today
the biggest one in the world what you
provide has to change a big box in a
mall or a solid location in a town where
you walk in and you buy it at a decent
price isn't good enough anymore
the same way as in nineteen fifty four
being in the downtown and being a
five-and-dime with toys at a good
healthy markup became vulnerable to Toys
R Us this is the thing that pisses me
off the I know nothing about the
brokerage industry I promise you the
brokerage thing disrupted something else
that existed in real estate 30 60 90
years ago
it's the same game Netflix is gonna get
Punk'd one day too because what happens
is people become complacent and so when
you hear that rant I just highly
recommend that you're thoughtful about
instead of saying [ __ ] that putting your
head in the sand and thinking it's about
a successful guy's opinion this is about
the [ __ ] Internet and it's gonna
[ __ ] break your face unless you ride
the wave because too many of you are
looking at the wave coming at you and
you think you're somebody because you've
had some success this thing is gonna
[ __ ] kill you
amen and and here's here's why I'm
passionate about it it shouldn't kill
you all you have to do is have the
humility and patience and work ethic to
grab that little surfboard that's right
here and jump on it and ride this thing
to the [ __ ] moon and my entire rant
this morning was you're way ahead of 98%
of the people because you wouldn't have
spent the money on the ticket to be here
if you weren't you have understand
actions louder than words
the fact that you know my content right
the fact that you even were in a funnel
the fact that so many of you travel how
many people here flew to be at this
conference that's [ __ ] ridiculous
that's ridiculous the fact that you're
there the fact that you're there you're
so close now the only thing that's
holding you back
is the money and how you're making it
now and the complacency in that what do
you want to leave everybody with what's
up what's a good general tone for what
you're seeing where you know from your
day-to-day life as an actual executor of
this craft as a personal brand that's
using a different medium as you're
getting the tone of the last talk and
this talk what's a good way to close out
these last couple of minutes what do you
think is a nuance or a thought starter
that's a little less theoretical because
I think you've established a great
overall strategy is there anything that
we haven't touched on in my talk or here
right now that you think may bring them
value oh I think that we listen I think
that a lot of people get nervous about
the idea of control which you talk about
a lot and if I'm gonna leave this group
with with anything and I have one thing
to show everybody right I want to make
sure that we we do that
Tom this is why I never am like the host
or the person that asked questions i
black out when I do talks literally
there was only one thing I had to do
here and I [ __ ] it up
so thank you for saving me don't worry
but obviously you're so good at what you
do
we're about to show you something pretty
rad we're proved sill right I know at
some point it was kind of like can we do
it can we not do it anyway
is that that's really true right yeah so
you're breaking the rules a little bit
yeah but I so yeah so control [ __ ]
control right take control your own life
[Music]